what is math
exactly it's a uh
a nice simplification
at this simple description
of what so we have a computer scientist
a physicist in the chemist here
why
i think the chemist is going to define
math and you guys can correct me
go for it i would say l and honestly
we're ready
i think the ability to um to label
objects and uh and place them into
classes and then do operations on the
objects is what math is
so on that point what does it mean to be
object first
versus information first so what what's
the difference between object and
information when you get to that low
fundamental level well i might change my
view so i'm stuff first the stuff
and then when stuff becomes objects it
has to invent information
and then the information acts on more
stuff and becomes more objects so i
think there is a transition to
information
that occurs when you go from stuff to
objects
yeah information is
emergent not emergent information is
actionable memories
from the universe
so when when memories become actionable
that's information
but there's always memory but it's not
actionable
yeah and then it's not information great
actionable is what you can create you
can use it
if you can't use it then it's not
information if you can't transmit it if
you if it doesn't have any causal
consequences in the forest i don't
understand why is that not information
it's not information it's it's um
it's uh stuff it's stuff happening but
it's not it's not causing yeah yeah we
can this is happening no not happening
requires information no no no no no
stuff is always happening no this is
where the physicists get and the
mathematicians get themselves in a loop
because they think the universe i mean
i think say max tegmark and and is very
playful and say like the universe
universe just math well the universe is
just math then we might as well not
bother having any conversation because
the conversation's already written we
just never go to the future and say can
you just give us the conversation it's
happened already so i think the problem
is that mathematicians
are so successful at labeling stuff and
so successful understanding of stuff
through those labels they forget that
actually the those labels had to emerge
and that information
had to be built on those memories so
memory in the universe so constraints
graph when they become actionable and
the graph can loop back on itself or
interact with other graphs and they can
intersect
those memories become actionable and
therefore their information and i think
you just changed my son my my mind on
something pretty big but i don't have a
pen so i can't i'm gonna write it down
later but roughly the idea is it's like
you've got these
these two graphs of objects of stuff
they have memories
and then when they intersect
and then they can act on each other
that's maybe the mechanism by which
information is then so then you can then
abstract so one when one graph can then
build another graph and say hey you'll
have to go for all the nonsense we have
to go through here's literally the way
to do it staff always comes first but
then when staff builds the abstraction
the abstraction can be then teleported
onto other structures is the looping
background yeah power
okay am i making i don't know i got
stuck yeah so first
a god made stuff
and after that
when you start to be able to uh form
abstractions that's when god is the
memory we the universe can remember
god is the memory the universe can't
remember
otherwise there's no way did you just
differ in that statement hundreds of
years from now what does that mean
i don't know what it means what does it
mean
okay wait we need to
how do we get onto this
we were
uh
time
causality mathematics
so what is mathematics in this uh
picture of stuff
objects
memory
and um
information
is
what is accurate mathematics it's the
most efficient labeling scheme that you
can apply to lots of different graphs
well the labeling scheme doesn't make it
sound useful can i try yeah sure please
have you rejected my definition of
mathematics i'm shocked yeah no i'm
sorry um but it's correct
oh sorry excellent um no i mean i think
um i think we have a problem right
because we we can't not be us like we're
stuck in the shells we are and we're
trying to observe the world and so
mathematics looks like it has certain
properties and i guess the thought
experiment i find is useful is to try to
imagine if you were outside of us
looking at us as physical systems using
mathematics what would be the specific
features you associate
to the property of
understanding mathematics and being able
to implement it in the universe
right
and um
and when you do that mathematics seems
to have some really interesting
properties relative to other kinds of
abstraction we might talk about like
language or artistic expression uh one
of those properties is the one i
mentioned already that is really easy to
copy between
physical media so if i give you a
mathematical statement you almost
immediately know what i mean if i tell
you the sky is blue you might say is it
goldball blue is it as your blue what
color blue do you mean and you have a
harder time visualizing what i actually
mean so mathematics carries a lot of
meaning with it when it's copied between
physical systems it's also the reason we
use it to communicate with computers
um and then the second one is it retains
its property of actually what it can do
in the universe when it's copied so the
example i like to give there is is think
about like newton's law of gravitation
um it's actually it's a it's a
compressed regularity of a bunch of uh
phenomena that we observe in the
universe but then it'll that information
actually is a causal in a sense that it
allows us to do things we wouldn't be
able to do without that particular
knowledge and that particular
abstraction and in this case like launch
satellites to space or send people to
mars or whatever it is um
so
so if you look at us from the outside
and you say what is it for physical
systems to invent a thing called
mathematics and then to use
uh
and and then
and then it to become a physical
observable mathematics is kind of like
the universally copyable information
that allows uh new possibility spaces to
be open in the future because it allows
this kind of ability to map one physical
system to another and actually
understand that the general principle as
well yeah so is it helping the
overlap of causal graphs then by mapping
oh well i think that's the explanation
for what it is in terms of the physical
theory of assembly would be some feature
of the structure of
the assembly spaces the causal graphs
and their relationship to each other so
for example and i mean this is things
that we're going to have to work out
over the next few years i mean we're in
totally uncharted conceptual territory
here um but
as as usual uh diving off the deep end
um but i would expect that we would be
able to come up with a theory of like
why is it that some physical systems can
communicate with each other
like language language is basically
because we're objects extended over time
and some of the history of that assembly
space actually overlaps and when we
communicate it's because we actually
have shared structure in our causal
history so let me have another quick go
at this right so i think we all agree so
i think um
we take mathematics for granted because
we've gone through this chain right of
you know um we all we all share a
language now okay and we can well we
share length so we have languages that
we can we can make interoperable
and and so whether you're speaking
i don't know all the different dialects
of chinese all the different dialects of
english
french german whatever you can
interconvert them the interesting thing
about mathematics now is that everybody
on planet earth every human being and
computers
share that common language that language
was constructed by a process in time so
what i'm trying to say is assembly
invented math is those those pro right
from the you know mathematics didn't
occur it didn't exist before life
abstraction was invented by life right
that doesn't mean that the universe
wasn't capable of mathematical things
you